build me like a vr zen zone to alleviate
stress and anxiety
just popping this on will be the
equivalent of years
of time off this is really impressive
what's up dude what's up nick how you
doing man good man a long time no see
well actually not that long
it feels a lot longer for me because i
was on vacation dude it was so good
i went kayaking it was like the chillest
thing in the whole world we went on utvs
utv is like an atv but it's like a car
the car version of an atv it's a
bigger thing you know get it dude going
on that vacation
i realized how much i needed that
vacation
stress was up dude anxiety was up i
would be happy just not to ever look at
that domino's video probably for another
year and then
i'll i'll come back to i'm like oh i
remember that one time and then the
stress might just
just just come back you never know i
can't just take a vacation
as much as i want to go on vacation with
a full-time job i've actually been
thinking
and i have an idea for a way for me to
actually be able to chill out when times
get really stressful when things get
really anxious at work
sam i know you're very busy man you've
got a lot of things going on oh yeah the
website's coming out
big news big deal i would appreciate if
you could set all that aside just for
maybe a day or two
and build me like a vr zen zone that i
can consistently go to while i'm working
here in the studio to
alleviate stress and anxiety i'm
actually super down any
chance i can get to build some cool
stuff and unreal i will
absolutely take it really yeah totally i
will totally do that
yes i literally have it open right now
i'm literally messing with it i just
needed something
to do i needed a little direction i'll
make something for you in unreal
it'll be vr it will be peaceful it will
make it so you do not have to leave the
studio to find
relaxation you know you can get a little
more work done
don't have to go out for a week you know
by yourself kind of win-win you know i
feel like that's this is actually
something maybe more people could get
some use out of like we're all locked
down we're not going out like we used to
and being able to pop like a vr headset
on and go into a customized unique
environment that is designed
to specifically relax you just you
and only you no one else i feel like we
would change the world
this is the features okay wait wait wait
wait this is the first one
in this zen zone whisper positive
like phrases positive like little maxims
and spongebob does put me at ease like i
love that show i can watch spongebob all
the time it's my comfort show so i'll
put that on the background when i'm
trying to chill so spongebob
good bob ross is chill but i think
spongebob is better
setting uh zen garden iceland perhaps
an iceland zen garden the temple in the
last samurai that ken wantanabe
chilled at definitely need to be a
librarian it's gotta be foggy not too
much but just enough
oh uh uh there's gotta be ambient music
in this thing like ambient music
singing bowls like a carpet in real life
would be then represented in vr
and that way it's an immersive element
where you will look at a carpet and
you'll feel the carpet as well
are you like into incense as well
because i'm starting to realize
chompers specifically do that's another
easy way to have a virtual thing
and a real world cue the light needs to
be shining
perfectly like god race god it's shining
beautifully from the heavens on to just
my little spot
from the heavens
from the heavens all right this is i
already have one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven but we've
just started uh let's see what else
uh masseuse uh i mean
yo yo yo masseuse give me like a
shoulder massage
and but it really it'll be you but i'm
not i'm imagining someone else
okay uh sure last time water feature
just some sort of like sam
sam special yeah we're gonna we're going
somewhere good with this
i just walked in on this not knowing
anything about what you guys are filming
right now are you suggesting
you're going to create a zen space for
clint just popping this on for
what five ten minutes in the studio will
be the equivalent of
years of time off um i think you can get
this done in a day
i don't fully have a plan but i do have
a list so to get
as much done and as little time possible
i used mostly assets from the unreal
marketplace and mixamo that were rigged
textured and ready to go in unreal
basically we've got our
japanese temple over here we got our
water feature in the form of a stream we
got some singing bowls and a
record player i'm supposed to integrate
positive asmr phrases
potentially some david goggins quotes uh
maybe a massage
here's here's my idea i can combine
multiple things
off his checklist if i virtually put
myself into that space
like the sam special what's more special
than me
i'm going in what i have to do is i
gotta put on a motion capture suit right
now
and relax clint to perfection
i am in your mind i'm in your mind
hey what's up clint diamond everything's
working we got my suit we got our face
hey let's build a facial motion capture
rig i like i need
to build one right now all right bro
this helmet sucks
it's incredibly uncomfortable hey there
we go we're getting the track
kind of yep seems like it's working here
you know what the main thing is i just
need the mouth movement to be synced up
more than anything else
because the motion capture suit the xn
suit it's one to one
meaning i need to set up my real world
environment just like the virtual one
i need to get a sense of my surroundings
here where is clint gonna be are there
any objects i need to interact with
how about this do you have a picture of
clint's face
there we go this is just gonna be my
place holder for clint
all right now how about this this stool
is gonna be like the record player
that's playing his cool dark ambient
music
this area right here will be the
exterior of the meditation area
dean's the bridge yeah but basically the
this lane in the studio will be my
area to roam let's see
i don't have much prepared yet but
that's that's what the phone's for right
hey let's not do that again shall we
[Music]
okay by this time these 15 minutes are
up i am gonna be
ready to take the suit off so hopefully
that helps my performance
are you ready to do this we're rolling
uh here we go
uh i didn't realize improvising for 15
minutes would be so hard
but i think it gets the point across as
long as clint comes out of it feeling
refreshed
then my job is done
how's it going sam this is straight up i
think it's
40 jank here's the thing all the fancy
things on the list that's where the
problems lie but just from the simple
relaxation standpoint
i tried to do as much as i could i guess
here's the thing clint is going to have
to just
tell us what he thinks about it like i
have done my best to make a relaxation
experience but the rest is up to him
it's it's ready for you okay
look stop looking i can't see anything i
can't see anything so clint i have to
warn you i have to warn you
i haven't tested this i haven't tested
the whole thing the whole your whole
experience
i've tested many parts of it i'd save
that first experience just for you since
it is built for you
it should be i'm just going to tell you
sometimes my character is no premise
on we're getting in i'm going to relax
as hard as possible right now here we go
clint i'm getting super nervous
i've got just the thing for you it will
ease your anxiety
is that specifically non-champa the
breeze
here we go sit down
dude oh this is great
this is this is really good dude wow the
carpet
[Music]
this is this is really impressive what's
up
um so yeah welcome to your
virtual meditation area
i hope you like it i got as many
features in as i possibly could
hope you like it i hope you're digging
this um
yeah just uh i'll i'll try and get out
of your way here
i can start the music for you here dark
ambient i know you love it
check it out oh my god
cool right yeah uh just hit me up if you
need anything i'll be uh
down here
oh my god dude that is that is something
special
this this incense feature is really whoa
he's back
your inner space which is nothingness
as silent and as empty as the sky
everything going good is this jill you
liking this
cool um got a few more quotes is that
going to get you in the mood maybe a
little bit here
um check this one out um
empty your mind become formless
shapeless uh like like water
he's definitely getting relaxed right
now you know he's smiling he's at ease
um it's not like the zen level of
relaxation i was looking for
but i just look at how much his spears
have been raised yeah stand up stand up
here
you what you want to do quick
wait turn around this way
yo yo yo can get a little deeper a
little harder
like a little harder and but really
it'll be you but i'm not i'm imagining
someone else like to the point where you
think i would be in pain
yeah i'll just yeah all done thanks sam
thanks sam dude i gotta stretch more
[Music]
[ __ ] he's smiling
he's taking deep breaths but what he
doesn't know
is that in a few minutes uh we have to
start
bringing him back out okay you know look
at this
this is not what a work environment
looks like and i hope that's the lesson
he learns
hello no no no click clint's
he i don't think he has his phone on him
yeah no he's uh he's in here he's
um he's he's still meditating oh wait he
was supposed to get that to you like an
hour ago
well that's that's fine but he's
probably it's like slightly stressful
no i'm not gonna fix that right now i
can't do that clint has to do that
only clint knows how to do that okay
yeah
i'll tell him to call you after after
this is over okay
oh it's really fun dude don't worry
about it for now he's
yeah i oh i got you covered
oh my god
[Applause]
i'm kind of creeped out a little creepy
there for a second
whoa
uh the incense thing caught on fire
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] who installed
who wants all the smoke in the temple
it's up there
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry about that man i must have like
the breeze must have knocked it over
yeah i forgot to mention earlier it's
been like it's like 12 13 minutes now
man
it's been kind of a while so uh yeah
take off the headset whenever you're
ready um i do have to use my computer
for a few things here in a second
um okay yeah seriously uh
are you gonna take this headset off okay
all right there we go and he took it off
all on his own
that was incredible that was all right
here's what it did for me honestly
here's what it honestly did for me and i
know you set out to like
chill me out and i kind of came into the
situation pretty chilled out but what it
did do
was raise my gratitude levels like
actually
raise my gratitude levels to the max you
blew my mind
i am kind of speechless at this point
like i'll come back to that
i will definitely come back to that that
was really funny and that was very
touching
that was very good i feel like i could
probably put some more spongebob in
there
dude no it was just enough it was just
enough spongebob like i don't know how i
turned around to catch that but i turned
around like it's the perfect moment to
see spongebob like
the phone call the phone call was so
funny yeah oh he was supposed to give
that to an hour ago like you needed it
an hour ago
oh he's the only one that can do it
dude and then the freaking fire the fire
alarm dude
ultimately it was about like it's
relaxation motivation
and then get back to work
that was crazy i'm super happy that sam
put that together and we wouldn't be
able to do it consistently if it weren't
for
our patrons so i'm going to do a yoga
pose for each one
of our patrons glitch cube
not a canadian spy allen almanza
phillip oxford i see paris
renzo patrick jordan
mattis podkar sunil s
[Music]
daniel webster phillip and thanks to the
rest of our patrons
really appreciate you guys we couldn't
do this consistently without you
so keep it up we'll keep it up check out
our patreon the links in the description
below